Fire in the hole!
Welcome back everyone this will be my full star
wars book of boba fett episode 4 video everyone
press f to pay respects to the sarlacc there's
a whole bunch of easter eggs so we'll break it
all down if you're brand new to the channel i'm
doing videos for all the episodes so be sure to
subscribe to get them we're also doing a disney
plus giveaway for memberships all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and just leave your
favorite easter egg from the episode on the video
a lot of really cool callbacks to return the jedi
of the original trilogy and a lot of foreshadowing
for i think some big easter eggs and cameo scenes
they're setting up for the last couple of episodes
but careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet because we have to talk about
everything i'll just start at the beginning
of the episode and we'll just work our way
through scene by scene talking about easter
eggs and moments as we go along starting with
the episode title chapter 4 the gathering storm
it's just meant to be a reference to the coming
war with the pike syndicate and boba fett's war
council that he has his loose alliance of jabba
the hutt's former akapos but the actual opening
scene is another back to tank flashback but it
seems like the last back the tank flashback we're
getting back to the events of what happened after
he burned the bodies of his fellow tuscan raider
tribe and just rode off on his bantha into the
desert they set up him taking back his ship the
slave one because at this point in the timeline a
couple years have gone by since return of the jedi
like he was in the sarlacc for a good long while
then was with the tuscans for what's implied
like a year or two couple years at least
they implied that right after jabba was killed
like right after his sail barge exploded and
people escaped bib fortuna immediately took
over his criminal empire so at this point
when he's rolling up to jabba's palace bib
fortune has been in power for a little while
but remember this scene is happening during
the events of the mandalorian season one
just before mando and grogu show up on tatooine
for the first time because right after he rides
out with his female bantha into the desert it's
taking place concurrently with the events of the
mandalorian season 1 episode 5. also i felt like
the scene of him eating with the bantha here like
roasting over the fire is meant to be a parallel
for mando and grogu sitting by the campfire
sort of the same vibe we also find out that his
bantha is female when the shots start going off
in the distance above the sand dunes they play the
mandalorian theme music q sounds just so there's
no mistaking what he's going to find when he rolls
up and we basically get a much bigger version of
that mandalorian season 1 episode 5 tag scene
of him rolling up to find fenix shan's body and
rescue her they explain the place where he takes
her is called a mod parlor and it's supposed to be
on the outskirts of mos eisley because obviously
the mandalorian and grogu are in most eisley at
this same time period and they don't want them to
overlap they don't want to break the continuity
because boba fett didn't actually cross paths with
the mandalorian until well into the mandalorian
season two so that's why they're like on the very
outskirts of town here and by the time he's rolled
up with her on his bantha because it moves so
slowly mando and grogu are probably long gone
they've already left the planet you spot the blue
swoop from present day so at some point ford in
this timeline here in the flashbacks the gang of
mods will steal this bike from this person here
after episode three they said all the different
colored swoop bikes were meant to be a 1950s
american graffiti reference which was george
lucas's big hit movie he did right before he
did star wars episode 4 a new hope but all these
people with the cybernetic implants are just
meant to be a callback to the references the water
merchant made in episode 3 about the gang members
upgrading themselves with implants and mods also
meant to foreshadow what boba fett is about to do
with fennek shand in order to save her life inside
the parlor there's a woman in an imperial uniform
because remember the empire is slowly coming
back like the remnants of the empire still around
they don't really wind up dealing them a huge
blow till the end of the mandalorian season too
and we still have grand admiral thrawn so there's
still a lot of empire out there in the distance
the doctor operating on everyone is our next big
celebrity guest cameo you might recognize him as
musician steven bruner aka thundercat if i'm not
mistaken here i believe some of the music that
they're playing here in the background while he's
modding her is some of thundercats actual music or
at least as a reference to his music he winds up
paying for her enhancements using the protection
money that the pikes had just given him before
he came back to find his tribe killed the thing
about not closing her up quote-unquote all the
beautiful machinery is meant to be a callback
to the mandalorian season 2 which actually
is technically forward in the timeline when
she revealed it to the mandalorian like check it
out and see look i got all these robot parts now
when they're talking to each other boba fett
reveals he knows who she is by reputation
because most of the bigger bounty hunters in the
galaxy become pretty infamous when he says she's
from the mid rim section of the galaxy it's this
region here these planets like naboo kashyyyk
she's also super surprised when he reveals that
he is boba fett because she also knows him from
his reputation as a bounty hunter but like a
lot of other people she's never seen his face
underneath the mask so he basically has to give
her the backstory of what happened to him after
he went into the sarlacc and how he was rescued by
the tuscans and became part of their tribe setting
up the payoff of him going after the red nicto
gang and the sarlacc itself he implies he'd be
able to get his ship back by himself from jabba's
palace if he had his armor but this is obviously
setting up the mandalorian season 2 when he does
get the armor back he's not wrong but it's also
meant to be a sly reference to cobb van who right
now when they're having this conversation is busy
walking around in boba fett's armor having bought
it off the jaws who literally ripped it off his
body because he was so weak really cool mini probe
droid that fennec shand uses to survey the inside
of jabba's palace they also use this as a clever
way to show us a bunch of the other places inside
jabba's palace that we haven't been to before
because it's a huge structure like you get a
good sense for the scale at the end of the episode
but up to this episode we've really only seen a
couple of the major rooms boba fett explains his
grand plan for getting his ship back then finding
his armor taking that back and then killing bib
fortuna to take jabba's throne because he doesn't
want to work for any more crap bosses anymore
but this is also setting up the mandalorian
season 2 like setting up the whole plot with him
going after his armor then obviously killing bib
fortuna in that mandalorian season 2 post credit
scene he also answers a bunch of questions about
what his plans were when he was still with the
tuscans before they got killed for those of you
that were wondering or had theories about him
staying with their tribe he basically says he
was planning on staying with them for the rest of
his life like leaving his life as boba fett the
bounty hunter behind completely they enter jabba's
palace through one of the sewage drains into the
kitchens which is another place another room in
the palace that we haven't been to before we find
another ev 9d9 droid acting as cook with another
different cooking droid the original ev 9d9 from
return of the jedi is actually canonically the
one that was bartending in the most island cantina
which we actually just saw during the mandalorian
season 1 episode 5 and we saw it again during
season 2 when he came back remember the first most
island cantina scene took place right before what
we're seeing play out here because that was before
they killed fenik shand fun fact 2 mark hamill
actually played the voice of that ev99 droid in
the cantina scene he says he actually does a lot
of uncredited voiceover roles in a ton of star
wars productions since the original trilogy so
eventually someday someone is gonna have to do a
super cut of all the mark hamill stealth cameos
they go full general grievous versus obi-wan
kenobi here with the chef droid and all the knives
hello there
and they both set up and pay off the joke about
the rat catcher droid coming to catch the rats
like what was that oh it was just a couple rats
like there's an actual tiny rat catcher droid
just running around the hallways of jabba's
palace when they entered the hangar bay and
started beating up all these gamorean guards i'm
wondering if these are the exact same ones that
he spared later in present day and are serving
him now as bodyguards there are actually a lot
more gomorian guards running around jabba's
palace like there's more than two but we've
never seen more than a couple of them in scenes
at any one time mostly for practical budgetary
reasons i think r.i.p to the gonk droid press f
to pay respects the gonk droid did nothing wrong
they wind up destroying another one of jabbo's
gifts left over for return of the jedi those are
the smaller transport ships they used to take han
solo chewbacca and luke skywalker to the sarlacc
a lot of sarlacc moments in this episode then
they escape and go after the red niktos to pay
them back for killing the tribe of tuscan raiders
just using the slave one's cannons it is not even
funny it's a complete slaughter real great quick
payoff scene they were never meant to be like
really huge villains like just a bunch of street
trash like you're a bunch of bugs and it's meant
to feel like a scene of old-school boba fett
just going all biblical on them then it's boba
fett versus the sarlacc round two in the way
they play this i love the jump scare that they
go for they play it kind of like a jaw scene like
you're waiting for the shark to just jump out of
the water when they lean in just a little too
close but i do like the way that they play with
the slave 1 ship here because the whole idea is
that it can rotate around so they just have a
little bit of fun with that too like hold on as
they rotate it to face downward into the sarlacc
like he's literally almost flying it into the
mouth of the sarlacc and even those sarlaccs are
really powerful there is no way that they
would have been able to get the slave one
entirely into its mouth given enough time it
might have been able to crush the cockpit and
then use its tendrils to like grab boba fett and
fennec shand and yank them out but as you can see
almost the cockpit itself covers the entire
mouth and the rest of the ship is just way
bigger so there's no way it would have ever
been able to fit the entire ship inside it
love the callback takedown of them using the
seismic charge again to kill it fire in the hall
when they've used it in this series now and
then back during the mandalorian season 2
it's more of a callback to attack of the clones
and the seismic charges during those scenes
but because we've already seen
this forward in the timeline in
the mandalorian season 2. you could also
think of it as callback to that as well
the other really cool reference to the mandalorian
season two episode one here that you may have
picked up on when they kill this sarlacc or the
sarlacc from return of the jedi is that during the
mandalorian season 2 episode 1 the crate dragon
that they all teamed up to take down had taken up
home in an abandoned sarlacc and they implied it
in that episode and kind of soft confirmed it in
this episode that the pit was the actual sarlacc
pit from return of the jedi and there's no more
starlight there because it was killed by boba
fett in this episode earlier in the timeline and
eventually the crate dragon came along and ate
its carcass and took up home in its former cave
i think the joke about not touching his buttons is
meant to be more of a mandalorian grogo reference
to all the times mando kept having to tell grogu
to not press his buttons fenix shan references the
back to tank after he comes out looking for
his actual armor inside the sarlacc because
he's covered in more stomach acid just literally
burning the flesh right off of his body slowly
also setting up all the back to tank scenes that
happen in the future even though we've been seeing
them in previous episodes the way they've been
playing the timeline when she says he's become
weak since living with the tuscans this is meant
to address all the people that have wondered about
what's going on with boba fett's big personality
change during the present day of the series like
a version of boba fett that tells jokes which
seems kind of weird if you've only seen him
during the original trilogy he explains he has
a much more efficient way for running a criminal
empire where they all make way more money and
there's way less senseless killing it is just
meant to be a reference to the principles
that he learned like the code that he took
from the tuscan raiders like he's going to run his
new tribe the way that they ran their tribe then
they actually flash forward to the mandalorian
season 2 post credit scene of him killing
bib fortuna because that was one of the next
things on this list after taking the armor back
and finishing his healing process in the back to
tank so i think that's supposed to mean that this
is the last time we'll see him have the back to
tank flashbacks when fennec shand references the
yazom that's the singing creature from max rebo's
band in the return of the jedi special edition
then they go back to the mos espa cantina to try
and recruit them one black kursantan if we've
learned anything from han solo and chewbacca it
always helps to have a giant wookie companion
also kind of helps that black krrsantan is such a
badass gonna need all the muscle he can get to go
after the pikes the way they play this scene at
black crysantan versus the trandocin's gambling
and madame garsa fwip talking him down makes
it seem like he's pissed about what happened
with the hutts like he didn't get paid on
that job because he didn't complete the job
but also they kind of imply that the trandoshan
may have had something to do with his time as a
slave in the fighting pits and they're
also making a reference to that scene
from a new hope with chewbacca almost losing
the game of dejarik to r2 d2 han solo's joke
about how wookies rip people's arms out of their
sockets when they lose games it's because a droid
don't pull people's arms out of their sockets
when they lose wookies are known to do that
so maybe he lost a bunch of money some of these
games to the trandoshans because he then literally
rips his arm right off you can also think of that
as a callback to the most iceland cantina scene
where obi-wan kenobi cut off panda baba's arm i
do kind of love the funny way they played this too
like given the choice of free booze and gambling
like getting his bar tab paid off or ripping off
the tran ocean's arm he chose the arm ripping like
the money he gives the tool twilight is meant to
settle his bar tab they also imply he's running
low on funds which sort of sets up him throwing
in with boba fett like looks like you could use
a job boba fett needs his muscle so it's a match
made in heaven and they have a very dark han solo
chewbacca vibe going on between them because black
krrsantan also still kind of owes boba fett for
setting him free i don't know if it's a life debt
necessarily so it's not exactly like chewbacca
and han solo but it's meant to be a twist on that
then they have their big war council meeting back
at jabba's palace where boba fett tries to get
all the different factions on most on board with
his plan for jabba's empire in fighting the pikes
is the trandoshans the aqualish and the
klatoonians and i love the way they have
the meeting itself like this giant dinner table
is literally inside jabba's throne room on top of
the grate to the raincore pit anytime you ever
have a scene in jabba's palace anytime anybody
gets near that great you're just waiting you're
just waiting for them to get trapdoored they pay
off the joke later when the cluetoonian captain
challenges boba fett asking him like why should
we just kill you on the spot in the baby rancor
rattles the great starts yelling before boba
fett feeds it under the table like a normal person
would feed a dog food underneath the dinner table
boba fett is still learning to ride that baby
rancor they might wait till episode 6 or even
the finale episode 7 to pay that off but because
they're teasing the baby rancor eating people
in this scene i think that they'll also pay
that off in the finale when they have their
giant battle with the pikes like there'll be a
giant battle in the finale like you would expect
but during that fight boba fett will roll in
riding the baby rancor and the baby rancor will
eat itself a ton of pikes robert rodriguez comes
back to cameo in the episode as the dokk strassie
character he's the trandoshan captain from episode
1. in the funny other cameo scene that you may
have recognized if you watched all the credits the
aqualish captain here garfield lockwalks is being
played by barry lowen who is actually pedro
pascal's stunt double as the mandalorian on
the mandalorian series a lot of the crews and the
stunt people will show up on the different series
because they typically film them one at a time
like they filmed the book of boba fett episodes
and then after they were done with that they tore
down those sets and set up the mandalorian season
three and they're filming that right now boba
fett explains to them how they'll earn way more
money using his plan than by throwing in with the
pikes but because they have a very game of thrones
vibe going on here around the table you're just
waiting for one of these factions to betray them
the lannisters and their regards also when he
tells them that they no longer have to pay him
tribute i think the idea is that he'll earn all
this money like the wealth that they'll gain that
he keeps talking about from the spice trade on
the planet but the funny thing is that boba fett
tells fenik shan that he's already basically rich
from credits from all of his earnings as a bounty
hunter all these years and when she talks about
looking for muscle quote-unquote early theory is
that that's foreshadowing for them hiring some
of the other major bounty hunter characters
from the original trilogy for those of you that
wanted to see some of them come back the ones
who are still alive in present day anyway and it's
probably a teaser for them bringing back the mando
and bo katan kryze the night owl characters like
he's going to hire the other mandalorians to
fight for him because they're superior warriors
and mando is very literally a bounty hunter who
will work for people that hire him flipping the
old script from boba fett no longer being hired
by other daimyos himself now hiring other bounty
hunters side note 2 the director of this episode
was kevin tancharoen he's directed a ton of marvel
tv episodes like agents of shield which ming na
herself comes from and he's done a bunch
of dctv episodes like the flash and arrow
so if you watch a lot of comic book shows you've
also probably seen episodes that he's directed
but if you spotted any of the big easter eggs
in the episode that i didn't talk about during
the video just write them below in the comments i
believe the idea is they saved a lot of the budget
for these last couple of episodes so if you felt
like episode 3 was kind of lackluster i feel like
this episode definitely made up for that it'll get
progressively crazier and crazier up to the finale
speaking of star wars 2 oscar isaac is now a
huge marvel character i just did a big moon night
trailer video you can click here to watch that and
click here for all my book of boba fett episode
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!